hey my name is Tammy elite and in this
video I wanted to share how I became
financially free in one week and I mean
I could just keep this all to myself
but it's too late now because the BBC
picked it up and it's been on in the
news I videoed myself during the week
and the videos got like 1.5 million
views and now everywhere I go I get
stopped in the street and people say to
me what exactly did you do Sam you'll
have do you become financially free in
one week through property if you haven't
seen the video feel free to check it out
the video I'll put a link right up here
and you can check it out but here's
effectively what I did so okay there's
two things you can do in property you
can be a property investor and a
property investor with someone that's
got a lot of money and they not
necessarily we usually they've got a lot
of money they don't know what to do with
it and they want it to be somewhere safe
and they put it into property that's
cool the other thing you can be is you
can be a property entrepreneur and a
property entrepreneur is somebody who
doesn't necessarily own property that
aren't necessarily invest certainly not
invest their own money into property
they make money in property and they do
that entrepreneurial and I have been in
property now for 11 years but I just did
this as like a social experiment and the
plan was no money in an area that I
don't know no credit literally nothing
no contacts zero and I'm gonna start
again from scratch and I think I did it
because I wanted to test the hypothesis
when people say you know people say if
you win the lottery you lose the money
again because you're not like good with
money and you just not used to do being
able to keep money control money make
money so you lose it but at the same
time if a wealthy person like Richard
Branson and they will be saying this if
Richard Branson lost everything he'd be
able to make it back real quick not
because of the fact that he got lucky
but because of what he knows and if Bill
Gates lost that he'd make it again and I
thought he's a true could a rich person
lose it and then make it back and I
guess not on not rich on the comparison
to these guys but I have built up quite
a large property portfolio and you know
I've got I've done quite well for myself
young guy bit of a portfolio
full time in property now so I thought I
wonder what would happen if I start
again from scratch giving myself this
social experiment this challenge and I
did it and I became financially free
meaning that by the end of the week I've
got a I've got a few properties and
making an income from those properties
which had systemized which meant that
technically I didn't have to work again
you know I was full-time in property and
I don't I did it from scratch so what
exactly did I do because even though
there's a video about it and even though
it's been on the news and stuff I guess
the people still asked me in the street
constantly when people seem is like dude
what did you do you know what strategies
did you use how can I do the same so
that's the reason for this video to
expose reveal and explain exactly step
by step what I did how I did it and my
thought process behind that and if you
guys want to go and have a bash and do
the same thing then that is awesome so
start now zero money now it's it's crazy
how little power you have and they'll
control you have when you have no money
at all so others at the start of the
week you know I was literally walking
around the street pigeons were flying
around I was hungry I was jealous of the
pigeons in fitted nothing and when
you've got nothing when you've got no
money you can't even afford to like
literally sometimes just go where you
want to go or eat what you want to eat
so it was a really tough first few days
and I knew that there was zero chance
that I'd be able to afford to buy a
property I couldn't get a loan I
couldn't get a mortgage because I had no
credit and what I decided to do was I
just thought if you want to be
successful you need to first add value
and if you can add value then this
success will follow so I literally
thought I need to find valuable
properties I need to find really good
juicy property investments that people
are going to be attracted to with a view
to them thinking I could maybe then sell
those leads so sell those deals on to
people to just give some quick cash so
that was my first kind of thoughts I was
also looking for properties that I could
control on a went to rent basis which
I'll get to in a minute so I'm just
literally for the first few days I'm
just viewing houses like crazy I'm going
around in an old yellow broken car that
was worth five hundred pounds
it was topped up with fuel but I'm
thinking I'm gonna run out soon and the
cars rubbish and I was viewing these
houses and I was just putting up forward
really really cheeky offers and I would
ring up agents before I I don't want to
waste my time because I knew that my you
know time is money and I'm very quickly
gonna be on the streets so I'll drink up
age
and just say hey I've seen this property
on the market for 102 thousand pounds
how motivated is the seller because to
be honest I'd only be able to buy it
through it like kind of high 80s Early
90s is it worth me booking reviewing or
not and if the estate agent was just
like oh no and then put the phone down
on me I've wasted 20 seconds if the
estate agent says you know what they've
really motivated they could accept that
offer then I'm like okay book me in so
I'm on the phone I'm making appointments
to see motivated sellers I'm speaking
with agents on viewing houses and
they're really cool developer who owned
like a massive whole estate with all
these luxury apartments and I was
thinking hmm I could do like a rent to
rent on these deals and there was so
much going on but I had no money even
though I had no money I was still
offering on properties as if I had money
because yeah if I went to this day agent
or these these sellers and just said oh
why though I have no money I'm flat
broke so can I put forward an offer they
get they're not going to even take me
seriously
I was embarrassed at my clothes I was
embarrassed of my car I was embarrassed
of having the money but I just kind of
felt the fear and did anyway and went
forward so I'm offering on these
properties and you know low and behold I
guess maybe where we are in uncertain
times with brexit and uncertainty and
things like that so people these sellers
were taking my office seriously and
sometimes also shrink embarrassingly low
and they were saying maybe if you got
just a little bit looking wow you know
this is this is awesome so when I start
getting these these deals and and
because I've got a good investment brand
I've been doing this for a long time I
can spot a really good deal if a deal
it's like a mechanic if you're you know
if you're if you're not into cars and
you're looking for old cars there might
be things really wrong with them and you
can't tell and you don't know what's
good or bad so you bring you know your
uncle who's a mechanic I'm that but not
for cars definitely for girls I'm not
for property so I'm going man and I'm
like see what's good seen what's bad and
the ones that are really juicy and I'm
like this seller so motivated I'm
thinking instead of me buying it myself
because I can't do that what I'll do is
I will negotiate a price find out what
they'll accept what their bottom line is
they're not just some due diligence
around the area
find out what the rents would be package
it up and then I'll then present that to
an investor now I don't know any
investors you know because I'm starting
from scratch and I can't really tap into
any contacts from what for my real life
because I'm doing this is a social
experiment so what I did was I just went
to some property networking events and I
went to some business networking events
I would literally just go anywhere I
could possibly go or knew there were
business people there were property
investors I'd go along and so what these
events are even like for free or next to
nothing like 10 pounds 20 pounds so I'm
thinking how can I get to the ones I can
get to for free now if you're wondering
and again this is a question I get asked
all the time people say how do you how
did you find these investors or how did
you get into these events listen just
Google if you just do all right now
property investing events or property
investing networking events or property
investors free seminars or or even
Business Network breakfast or this sort
of stuff if you search to sell stuff
what you'll find is there's absolutely
dozens of these kind of breakfasts and
dinners and events and conferences going
on all over the UK all the time so I
went to some of these events and I've
got these deals and now what I'm
thinking is I can't buy them I'm gonna
have to marry the invest much with the
invest or and our charge of fee in the
middle maybe like because because here's
the thing if I found a property that's
worth 150,000 and I've agreed to buy it
for a hundred thousand
that's a 50,000 pound discount could I
pass that on to somebody and say I just
want five thousand I mean they're still
making forty five thousand pound
discount instead of fifty thousand
they're gonna pay me the five thousand
of course so I'm sort of just networking
and I'm saying hey I've got these
investments and I'm shown that the
details and it's it's hard don't get me
wrong because people are like who is
this guy and you know we don't know you
how can we trust you so it was difficult
but again why with my experience of
sales and and had a closed deal and how
to persuade people
I used absolutely brought my a-game and
I was just like really trying to close
the deal so I'd say listen if this would
be my script
if the deals as good as I'm saying and
if it is and you had all the time in the
world check it out and if you're really
getting that kinda bit of scout would
you be prepared to pay a two thousand
pound today and they'll say well yeah I
would if the deal was that good
okay well listen how about this pay me
the two thousand pounds fee and then
we'll get some terms and conditions
signed and I'll give you 14 days to go
do all your due diligence and if what
I've said is not true then you'll get
your two thousand pounds back but if it
is true than you're obviously gonna be
really happy it sounds like we have a
deal and I was just speaking like this
and in the end I managed to sell it took
a while and it was really hard and if
you want to watch the full documentary
again there's a link but if you want to
watch the end in description as well
this with the full kind of half an hour
you'll watch me do this but you'll see
it was hard
it wasn't easy but I managed to sell
three deals and I put a two thousand
pound see I'm one of them and then the
other two I charged three thousand so I
made eight thousand pounds profit
cash in my bank just by packaging and
selling deals and I did that literally
within the first few days of doing this
challenge and it's just like oh my
goodness I guess at that point I wanted
to pinch myself because it showed me
that even if I was stripped from
everything in real life and I lost this
house and I lost you know my business
and I lost all my properties and things
went wrong the skills that I've got ah
been able to negotiate I've been able to
find a deal spot deal package a deal
sell a deal like at least I'd be okay
right I'd be able to make a good living
so I've got this eight thousand pound
now now the problem is if I want to
become financially free that means that
I've got to have a passive income
meaning I need to be getting a recurring
income whereas packaging and selling
deals that's not recurring income I've
got a real hustle hard to get the money
whereas I want a passive income from
property or from rent from rental income
which is recurring how do I get that
eight thousand pounds is not enough
money to to to buy a house it just isn't
especially if you've got no credit I
mean how can you physically buy a house
for eight thousand pounds I guess you
might be able to potentially buy like a
shed or something but we've no ability
to get a mortgage and with no credit it
doesn't man is just not enough so at
this point what I'm deciding to do is
instead of
buying the property I'm just gonna take
take control of the property Warren
Buffett says own nothing control
everything some of the most successful
companies on the planet uses strategy
which is called rent to rent they don't
tell you they do read to ramps because
they don't want you to know what they're
doing of course but that is what they do
so if you research companies like Regis
and we work we work it's a global
company and they're like these guys that
are billionaires okay so the closet
setup we work and the god that we just a
billionaire with a B that's a million a
million a million a million a million a
million a million thousand times and
what they do is they use a strategy
called went to rent and how they do it
is they also we work for instance
they'll rent a big office block off of a
an owner so an investor who happens to
own a big massive office building
they'll we work will say hey we will
rent the whole building off you will do
a 15-year lease you'll have no voids no
maintenance no issues no management
we'll pay you X so it's the froggen is
like let's say they'll say five thousand
pound a month for this for this for this
building because hypothetical figure but
let's say five thousand and then what
they'll do is they will then rent out
the office blocks but they'll rent it
out unit by unit and they'll turn it
into a boutique luxury serviced offices
and they'll not charge they might charge
like a thousand pounds per unit with 15
units so that their their rent is got
there's now fifteen thousand pound of
that fifteen thousand pounds they're
gonna have to give five thousand to the
owner
five thousand argument's sake is going
to go towards costs and maintenance and
then five thousand is going to be their
profit so they're making five thousand
the owners making five thousand so how
is it fair that the owners only making
five thousand when the owner owns it and
the owner probably have to invest
hundreds of thousands of pounds buying
this building so the owners making five
thousand but they're making five
thousand and they can put any money down
apart from maybe making your luxury the
difference is they're the entrepreneur
and the owners the investor so
there the person that added the most
value there the person that was creative
so how can i with just eight thousand
pounds do the same thing but on a much
smaller scale so what I did was I did
something called rent to rent which is
again you rent it off the owner and then
you rent it out in a different way so
you pay a small rent and then you get a
super rent by being creative so on a
small level starting from scratch with
nothing but 8,000 pounds while I did was
the developer you have the all these
nice apartment I said to him how much in
your apartment and he told me and and
the apartments weren't that expensive it
was like six hundred and fifty pounds
there was a beautiful luxury penthouse
that already have some furnace room
really really nice
over viewing the city and that was on
four twelve hundred pounds so it's not
bad for like a four-bed penthouse so
what I said and this was in Sheffield by
the way which was which were I was doing
the challenge because I said to the
developer the owner is there are more
good she said no I said is asking some
questions I said how about I'll pay you
the rent I got a little bit less but
just so you know just we can be
transparent or I'm not going to be live
in there myself it'll be a corporate
management agreement and I'll be renting
out as like luxury stay for people on
booking.com and Airbnb is that something
that would be you'd be happy with is
that something that levy would work with
in the women what you've got and then in
the head least everything now he owns
the whole thing there's no mortgage on
the property we have a conversation and
in the end he agrees she says you have a
deal as long as you pay me on time you
know and everything will see if it goes
so I'm like yes so I then had to pay him
upfront rent I had to furnish the
property a little bit but it only cost
me five thousand pound so our of the
eight thousand pound five thousand
pounds I've never got these two looks
reinterred them both out within days
like literally days and then stop
booking calm and everybody with mad I
used to channel management company
called a VEVO and they basically
systemized everything to make sure that
it's passive for me I've got a cleaning
company to arrange to go in and out each
time and I was getting like 80 100 120
pound a night now you can do the math so
if you've got two properties and you're
getting that kind of amount per night
and sometimes you can you can
was it because there's like four
bedrooms in the penthouse or if it's
holiday season you can really maximize
it you can work out how much profit I
was making so I was making just over two
thousand pound a month from these two
properties I don't own them but I'm
controlling them
and I'm like oh my gosh I've now made
eight thousand pound I've got two
properties they've got the keys for and
they're renting out I did that only took
me seven days one week
that's extra three thousand pounds of
the eight that I didn't need the three I
gave away to charity to a homeless
charity because I thought well at the
end of the day I'm really fortunate that
I can do this
so gave the three thousand pound to a
homeless charity those apartments are
still renting out they're still
operating amazingly well and that's what
I did that's how I did it so if you see
me in the street now and you asked me
what on earth happens then I can happily
sit down with you're a copy but you can
also watch this video and it might save
my voice
thanks so much watch the video as well
please do smash the like button if you
enjoyed it if you didn't like the video
there may be so much to dislike learn it
doesn't matter because from the YouTube
algorithms is the exact same thing also
if you've not watched the video the me
actually doing this I'd really suggest
checking it out all right you can do
that right yeah also if you'd like to
watch me helping somebody else become
financially free in one week which I
also did you can watch that right yeah
if you'd like to come and spend a couple
of days with me on the property
investors crash course you can do that
up here and also don't forget subscribe
down here thanks so much guys peace out